so now you can see the reaction is
really going and it's really exothermic
we're forming aluminium triiodide and
the exotherm is is actually heating and
starting to sublime off the excess
iodine which you can see coming off as
is really nice purple plume and ian's
beautifully colored element it has this
beautiful purple color if you put it in
solution the color of the solution
varies depending what you dissolve it in
if you dissolve it in water it's a sort
of dirty brown color if you dissolve it
in an organic material like chloroform
or carbon tetrachloride it is a
beautiful purple color but in Zara is a
halide a halogen element from the far
right hand side of the periodic table
and strongly oxidizing in nature I
sneaked electrons off of an other atoms
so what we're going to do is we're going
to do a reaction with with iodine and
today we've ground some iodine so it's
normally found from chemical suppliers
as really nice large crystals but what
we want to do is a reaction with it when
we need to make sure that the surface
area of the iodine is really really
large so that all of it can react very
very quickly with the other component
iodine also occurs quite widely in
nature and is absolutely essential to
life if you don't have ID in your
thyroid gland which is a small gland
that controls development of all sorts
of things in your body doesn't operate
properly nowadays iodide is added to
table salt in countries like the UK and
most other developed countries so nearly
everybody has enough iodine in the old
days I Dean had to be got from the
environment and usually from the spray
from the sea that was blown across the
land and so in Nottingham which is
really near the centre of England a long
way from the sea or relatively long way
from the sea there were serious
illnesses caused by people not having
enough iodine so called goiter
which caused a swelling the thyroid
grande gets bigger and this used to be
called Derbyshire neck this unpleasant
illness because it happened in this area
of Nottingham and Derbyshire
so what we're going to do is we're going
to mix it now with another element and
that element is aluminium so aluminium
has electrons to give away iodine is
going to nab them going to see some
oxidation chemistry in the formation of
a new compound which is aluminium
triiodide it's a really nice chemical
reaction but the way that we do is we
mix the two together and then we we have
to add water which acts a bit like a
solvent but also the oxygen in the water
activates the iodine so it becomes more
strongly oxidising and then hopefully
we'll see the new reaction so I'm just
going to put some out into this small
vessel the you can see this development
effect of iodine really well but if you
have tadpoles baby frogs they don't
develop their legs and turn into frogs
unless there is adding in the water the
other components in this reaction is
aluminium okay and we're using very very
finely powdered aluminium not foil or
not a lot rather large lump this has
been specially powdered for us so again
it has a very very high surface area one
of my favourite chemical equations is
tadpoles plus adding goats to frogs so
you can see the aluminium and the iodine
mixed within this solid mixture
now still these two components these two
up elements they're still held away from
one another they can't react so what we
need to do is add a small amount of
water which acts a bit like a solvent
but it also activates your diene and
then we'll wait and see what happens
with the chemical reaction a DIN can be
used as a disinfectant in fact chlorine
can be as well but a solution of iodine
is often used when people have cuts so
if you cut yourself unfortunately I
haven't any cuts at the moment you can
paint on iodine and because of its
rather red color it made cuts often look
much worse children would come home from
school and their whole hand would be red
and this would cause some excitement at
home but it is quite an effective
antiseptic water just take a small
amount and add it to the reaction so you
can see it's starting to go now the
chemical reaction because we're seeing
the excess iodine subliming and forming
a vapor now if we're going close we can
hear it fizzing because this is actually
the oxidation reaction and the formation
of the new aluminium triiodide now I'm
going to react just mix this slightly to
try and increase the rate of the
chemical reaction slightly so now you
can see the reaction is really going and
it's really exothermic we're forming
aluminium triiodide and the exotherm is
is actually heating and starting to
sublime off the excess iodine which you
can see coming off is this really nice
purple plume now deep inside the
reaction air you can see the the
exothermic it will the energy coming out
and starting to cause a flame really
really nice very very rapid chemical
reaction really beautiful so we're
forming aluminium triiodide here which
again is a very very delicate compound
quite reactive in itself but you can see
now the really nice new crystalline
material so sadly we've managed to stain
the stig's fume cupboard all of this
really nice iodine for me
fine layer across is humid what do you
think about that